[Musique]
après les parisiens après les
marseillais après les anglais cette fois
ci nous sommes en suisse alors vous
connaissez le principe on se prend des
panneaux des poteaux des murs dans le
but de tester la bienveillance des gens
de cette fois ci on a voulu renouveler
un peu le concept pas que ce soit
redondant on a fait appel à un guest un
invité un peu spéciale du web
khouildi le président et le coach dd oui
oui si tu as dit julien inscrits et
chaud moi j'ai chaud mais j'ai un peu
peur quand même clairement faire ma
petite guerre ok 3 2 1 c'est parti
en huit ans c'est de la merde [ __ ] y'a
plein de merde
bon c'était pas une bonne idée première
chute échec la mer
[Musique]
j'étais en train de tomber et je me suis
pris l'avis traque plus mon bras droit
[ __ ] la belle époque là lé ton fils et
l'autre toujours fait les bons usages
audap depuis hier 14 heures attendez je
vois si j'arrive à dabou croisade au oui
oui a du mérite friction de tête elle le
met en pls squeeze s'écrit au quai
bonsoir et cela bouge pas tant le bush
ne bouge pas et c'est pas un autre ami
nous ont filmé là et on l'a vu donc on a
fait n'est pas ce qu'on veut ça marrant
fait que moi je veux pas être là dessus
elle m'avait tout de suite ça vous
n'avez pas youtube
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
d'accord ok vous êtes huysman oui je
suis dérange pas du tout vous enlevez la
partie je suis ou j'appelle les flics
supprimés c'est toi je sais même pas où
il est le truc et regarde vers nous et
en plus il s'est trompé le panneau ici
il a été surpris par la voie du mec est
ce que vous pouvez me prêtez votre bob
il a une obsession avec les couvre-chefs
cervidés revanche si je garde le baume
comprends je crois qu'on peut dire que
le grand givet a réussit son premier as
pas convenir un paquet on lui avait dit
de parler de pokémon parce qu'il a un
peu peur en impro donc le gars a juste
dit pokémon la juste dit le monde
pokémon
alors c'était comment bonne répartie
vous êtes couché c'est ça vous êtes
couché debout
ok c'est inception on est à 90 dollars
versés qu'est ce que vous foutez dans ma
cuisine c'est bon j'ai deux bouts c'est
branché de vous c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon
bloqué au web sortez moi de là bordel
[Musique]
ils vont présenter
ch
du coup c'est complètement faux
il s'est frotté au contraire
[Musique]
bonjour maintenant tu as bien changé
mais c'est toujours aussi douce
il eut perdu le gars il comprend pas ce
qu'il va bien tapé il s'en passe il
coule encore vous avez pas vu là je suis
au paradis
non vous êtes à genève mon choix oui je
suis au paradis fiscale de la suisse à
genève c'est pourquoi il est rentré
d'entre nous on peut dire je suis tombé
dans le panneau
[Musique]
c'est typiquement ce qu'il faut quand
elles sont un peu coincé sans
globalement complètement
il est tombé sur la mamie qu'elle à
moins qu'on ait série cap on va vous
n'êtes pas une mamie pour moi vous êtes
une star je vais là-bas - c'est parti
l'amour l'amour et globale aux vivants
vous auriez pu avoir un trauma ou un
bleu
il sonne clicquot qui sont la saison
tout puissant pack et quia matin le gars
qui sont débattues il était là haut
c'est fou
ah bah voilà voilà la seule personne qui
pourrait m'aider c'est cette magnifique
enfants m'aident à me relever trop bien
se trouver un enfant garde - la main non
j'ai un ange sur têt la conclusion vous
l'a tiré de vous même c'est mais oui
merci
c'est toi de la meilleure qui réellement
ému les indics c'est la merde les
enfants c'est le bonheur les adultes
c'est la mer ils ont pensé le chrono
attendez attendez attendez reculer
reculé tout ce recueil de mon réguler
tous ses bons coups merci j'ai réussi sa
chute il des autres
il a réussi à marier quoi toi comme les
autres m'expliquer ce que vous avez un
emballage courait pour attraper le bus
et je me suis pris le truc je n'ai pas
vu les gars voulaient pas me passer
votre bébé qui vous appeler sylvie
chaque fois il dit 6 nuits dans tous les
épisodes il dit si je vais y aller non
mais c'est gentil merci je vais y aller
revoir passé nous avons vécu une
deuxième fois sur deux est ce qu'on fait
là merci de m'avoir issue et la bave
attendez je vais essayer d'y aller sans
comprendre le truc 3 2
merde je n'arrive pas à sortir de cette
zone
je parle là encore une fois ok vous êtes
un robert faire regarder c'est une
caméra cachée c'est le meilleur gardien
timo pour youtube fait chier
que c'est une soirée girly tu vois on
est entre personne humaine voilà il n'y
a pas de différence en fait là on est
entre amis entre potes
moi je veux pas de ton ami
[Musique]